y
[Música]
la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu envió una carta a
los legisladores indicando que está
lista para iniciar el proceso con el que
se activara el juicio político contra el
presidente saliente de donald trump ya
son dos los senadores republicanos que
se unen a los demócratas pidiendo las
renuncias del mandatario al considerar
que incitó el asalto del pasado
miércoles al congreso por el que se han
abierto al menos 25 casos por terrorismo
doméstico méxico confirmó el primer caso
de la variante británica de kobe 19 se
trata de una persona que se encuentra en
el estado de tamaulipas en el norte del
país con ello méxico se convierte en la
cuarta nación de la región en
identificar contagios con dicha mutación
tras localizar las cajas negras del
avión de pasajeros que se estrelló este
sábado con 62 personas a bordo las
autoridades indonesias indicaron que es
posible que la aeronave se haya partido
en pedazos al impactar contra el mar los
restos de los fallecidos están siendo
recuperados al tiempo que expertos toman
muestras de adn de los familiares de los
viajeros para su identificación
gracias por continuar con nosotros aquí
en france24 soy valentina torre sánchez
comenzamos el informativo en eeuu un
segundo senador republicano se ha unido
al llamado para que donald trump
renuncia a la presidencia antes del 20
de enero el mandatario estadounidense se
enfrenta a la posibilidad de ser
sometido a un nuevo juicio político tras
ser señalado de haber incitado a la
insurrección por la toma del capitolio
justamente este domingo la presidenta de
la cámara de representantes nancy pelosi
se declaró lista para activar ese
segundo juicio político barinas
arguiñano se amplía
los demócratas presentarán este lunes
ante la cámara de representantes- una
resolución para pedir al vicepresidente
saliente mike pence la invocación de la
enmienda 25 a quien le dan 24 horas para
contestar de no hacerlo los legisladores
demócratas pasarán a activar un juicio
político contra donald trump según la
presidenta de la cámara baja nancy
pelosi al proteger nuestra constitución
y nuestra democracia actuaremos con
urgencia porque este presidente
representa una amenaza inminente para
ambos a medida que pasan los días se
intensifica el horror del continuo
asalto a nuestra democracia perpetrado
por este presidente también la necesidad
inmediata de actuar cada vez son más las
voces republicanas que se unen en
repudio al presidente saliente de eeuu
el domingo- patrick tú mi senador por
pensilvania se convirtió en el segundo
republicano en pedir la renuncia de
trump por incitación a la insurrección
bueno creo que la mejor opción para
nuestro país es que el presidente
renuncia y se vaya lo antes posible
reconozco que puede que no sea probable
pero creo que sería lo mejor no parece
que exista la voluntad o el consenso
para ejercerlo
opción de la enmienda 25 y no creo que
haya tiempo para hacer un juicio
político
quedan 10 días antes de que el
presidente se vaya de todos modos creo
que lo mejor sería una renuncia
tú me se suma así a la senadora por
alaska lisa murkowski que ya había hecho
lo propio y otro senador de nebraska
pensás que dijo que consideraría los
artículos de impeachment si la cámara
los aprueba tras recibir una oleada de
críticas la casa blanca hizo ondear la
bandera a media asta cinco días después
de la muerte del oficial bryant sic ni
el domingo fue homenajeado por sus
compañeros
una encuesta davis in you shape sort
revela que más de la mitad de los
estadounidenses quieren que el
presidente abandone el cargo antes del
20 de enero hablamos ahora de ccoo y 19
y vamos a méxico que se convirtió en el
cuarto país de américa latina en
confirmar la presencia de la variante
británica de kobe 19 en su territorio
las autoridades informaron que se trata
de un viajero internacional que llegó al
estado de tamaulipas desde ciudad de
méxico nuestro corresponsal 'mario
carbonell nos da más detalles
en el norteño estado de tamaulipas
registró la presencia de la nueva cepa
del virus sars cop 2 conocida como be
117 y que aqueja al reino unido- se
trata de un hombre de 56 años que llegó
a la ciudad fronteriza de matamoros el
pasado 29 de diciembre procedente de la
ciudad de méxico en un vuelo
internacional así lo confirmó la
secretaria de salud de tamaulipas gloria
molina gamboa quien aseguró que de
manera inmediata se aplicó el protocolo
sanitario al personal de tripulación y a
los pasajeros de ese vuelo pero las
pruebas resultaron negativas
méxico no tiene ningún tipo de
restricciones para visitantes
extranjeros ya sea por trabajo o para
turismo este contagio con la nueva cepa
se da en un momento en que la pandemia
está en su punto más complicado y cuando
la ciudad de mexico y el estado de
méxico han prolongado el color rojo del
semáforo epidemiológico por la
saturación hospitalaria el país acumula
más de un millón y medio de casos
positivos confirmados y supera a las 133
mil muertes
vamos a israel porque el gobierno
anunció que a sólo tres semanas de
iniciar la campaña de inmunización el
20% de la población ya recibió la
primera dosis de la vacuna de facer
bayón tec el porcentaje equivale a 1,8
millones de personas las autoridades
explicaron que este domingo se empezó a
suministrar la segunda dosis al personal
sanitario
entretanto las autoridades sanitarias de
japón detectaron una nueva variante que
aparentemente sería distinta a las
identificadas en reino unido- y
sudáfrica se trata de dos hombres y dos
mujeres que regresaron al país
provenientes de la amazonas brasileño
tres de los contagiados mostraron
síntomas como dificultad para respirar
fiebre y dolor de garganta
cambiamos de tema y vamos a indonesia
porque en menos de 48 horas las
autoridades se encontraron las cajas
negras del avión comercial que este
sábado se estrelló en el mar con 62
personas a bordo ahora la investigación
se centra en recuperarlas y en continuar
la búsqueda de víctimas y de las partes
más grandes del aparato según expertos
la aeronave pudo haberse partido en
pedazos al impactar contra el mar
un voto de rescate para parte de los
restos del avión comercial de la
aerolínea sriwijaya su vuelo sj 182 dejó
trozos metálicos y restos humanos que
están siendo examinados dentro de una
gran operación de búsqueda y salvamento
un equipo de buzos ha ido recuperando
los escombros a una profundidad de 23
metros en el mar dejaba frente a la
costa de yakarta
si bien el cómo y el porqué de esa caída
es para responderse con la información
de las cajas negras ya localizadas las
señales emitidas por las dos cajas
negras están siendo monitoreadas
continuamente para que podamos marcar
sus coordenadas con suerte pronto
podremos recuperarlas y enviarlas al
comité nacional de seguridad del
transporte su investigación ha sido
ordenada por el presidente indonesio yo
con cuidado quien ofreció condolencias a
los familiares a panamá contenta yo en
nombre del gobierno y de todo el pueblo
indonesio expresó mi más sentido pésame
por esta tragedia
estamos haciendo todo lo posible por
encontrar y salvar a las víctimas como
uganda el sábado la tripulación del
sriwijaya air perdió el contacto con la
torre de control cuatro minutos después
del despegue en yakarta rumbo a la
ciudad de pontiac 62
personas iban a bordo del boeing 737 500
de 26 años de antigüedad que según el
director ejecutivo estaba en buenas
condiciones
indonesia tiene una larga historia de
accidentes aéreos el último ocurrió en
2018 y también involucró a un boeing
aunque del modelo 737 máx 189 personas
murieron entonces cuando el vuelo de
lionel se hundió en el mar dejaba un
vuelo que puede considerarse un caso
aparte ya que se debió a problemas del
modelo y no de una deficiente
supervisión de seguridad
finalizamos en españa' porque la
tormenta filomena sigue golpeando el
centro del país aunque el aeropuerto de
madrid- ha retomado gradualmente sus
operaciones y se confirmó la entrega del
próximo lote de vacunas ahora la
atención se centra en el frío extremo
que se prevé para los próximos días
veamos más detalles en el informe de
alva santana
filomena sigue dejando estragos en
españa' con el avance del temporal se
espera el cese de las nevadas y la
llegada de una ola de frío con
temperaturas que alcanzarían los menos
10 grados centígrados tras una reunión
de emergencia el gobierno informó que se
cumplieran con los plazos de vacunación
contra el cubit 19 como estaba previsto
el aeropuerto que podemos decir que
podría ser un poco más preocupante es el
de barajas pero está previsto que en la
madrugada de hoy en la madrugada próxima
del lunes pueda aterrizar un vuelo con
las dosis de esta semana y que podamos y
tomamos todas las medidas precisas para
evidentemente su distribución posterior
en los centros sanitarios de las
comunidades correspondientes el
aeropuerto de barajas- cerrado desde el
8 de enero reabrirá gradualmente y se
prevé que lleguen varios vuelos con
alimentos y vacunas a las zonas que han
quedado aisladas por el temporal ahora
el gobierno advierte de la importancia
de seguir con las indicaciones para
enfrentar la ola de frío
no debemos bajar la guardia mantengamos
la alerta y previsión ante la llegada
mañana de la ola de frío sigamos las
indicaciones de los servicios de
emergencia y evitemos los
desplazamientos por nuestra seguridad y
para garantizar los servicios esenciales
y el abastecimiento
la tormenta deja hasta el momento 4
personas muertas así como el
desabastecimiento de alimentos en
supermercados y una fuerte reducción de
la movilidad a ustedes muchas gracias
por acompañarme en esta jornada pueden
ampliar toda la información en nuestra
web france24 puntocom volvemos en breve
con más noticias
[Música]